a company in Southern California has  created an Abraham Lincoln animatronic  robot that's able to make incredibly  realistic facial expressions here's a  sample of what this amazing robot is  capable of this is real take a look  [Music]  yeah it's pretty pretty amazing anyway  we thought I'd be interesting to see  once again what this robot does when  shown some clips of our current US  president let's take a look and as I  said they will be met with fire fury and  frankly power the likes of which this  world has never seen before  thank you he referred to my hands of  their small something else must be small  I guarantee you there's no problem I  guarantee I said that if Ivanka weren't  my daughter perhaps I'd be dating her  we're sorry  you